what is up reject nation we are going to
watch today from new rock stars shang
ching the legend of the 10 rings full
movie breakdown in easter eggs from eric
voss of course you know we just did our
shongxi live stream spoiler talk
appreciate everyone who chimed in for
that we checked out their uh
post-credits scene breakdown but i feel
like the journey is just not complete
until we watch this let's end it here
but of course more speculation is gonna
come you know you know how these marvel
movies go let's do it
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and shang chi in the legend of the
10 rings introduces a new avenger to the
mcu deeply rooted in mystic mythology
unafraid to pose cryptic questions about
the monsters in the shadows of our
dimension and the wonderful weirdos wong
has been hanging out with i'm gonna
break down this film scene by scene for
all the deeper layers of meaning and the
marvel easter eggs that you might have
missed the film opens on the black flag
of the ten rings the army of win woo
played by the great tony liang who
possesses the 10 rings now the tan rings
organization has appeared in the mcu
since the beginning the terrorist
network who kidnapped tony stark and the
first iron man the operative who aided
ivan vanco and iron man 2 the weapons
buyer and ant-man and of course
iconography appropriated in iron man 3
by aldrich killian and the false
mandarin the paid actor trevor slattery
who actually returns in this film after
being extracted from seagate prison by
forces of the true mandarin in the 2014
short film all hail the king now
viewable on disney plus you know what
just made me realize we're never gonna
see a proper showdown between iron man
and his arch nemesis the mandarin that's
not unfortunate for like robert downey
jr is pretty dead set on never returning
maybe like that iron heart series that's
what everyone's hoping for maybe he'll
go up against rio williams
nemesis or rio williams and jai ling
might go toe-to-toe or something like
that if she becomes the next mandarin or
something of that nature just hit me
right now in this moment like oh crap
we're never going to see that no classic
match-up but then again never say never
when it comes to marvel but here on this
flag the ten rings logo has had its
central weapons replaced with the hook
swords used by win woo's warriors and
within each of these rings is a
character from an ancient chinese
calligraphy known as sealscript going
from the top it means power or authority
clockwise to the right means physical
strength the third means strong or
robust yeah a lot of these translate to
some version of strength or power kind
of like the ten rings
the fourth means extraordinary
magnificent or great the fifth means
hero heroic or outstanding person the
sixth means power influence
and the tenth means pump or power all of
those mean male genitals specifically
john's male genitals right there the ten
rings are based on my pack
based on john's genitalia i'm so happy
for you your balls finally got a shout
out that's right it did
in the asian pride movie now wenwu
himself is based on the iron man villain
of the mandarin for the marvel comics
later renamed zhang zhu but he's also
kind of based on shang chi's traditional
father a character known as fu manchu
yes another bit of very problematic
history that marvel has retconned over
the years what the hell are you talking
about
my comic book technology each containing
the spirit of a cosmic warrior giving
each ring a different ability but here
the film reconceives them as equally
powered wrist bracelets evoking the iron
strength bracelets of chinese martial
arts like hungar the mandarin in the
comics found on the clown rings in the
crashed alien spacecraft of axon carr
and later on in this film it is said
that win woo might have found them in a
crater or a tomb but it's never
confirmed though it looks like the post
credit scene starts to go more into
their origin yeah you see that's
something that i kind of i'm hoping that
if they expand upon the ten rings to a
certain extent that they can give each
ring more of an individual identity the
way how the ten rings are in the comics
themselves because it's something we
still haven't gotten it done i think
it's perfect for the story they chose to
tell this time around and what they
ultimately symbolize and how there's so
much emotional context surrounding the
use of the ten rings clearly there's
still so much more to unpack there so
maybe it has something to do with the
cosmic souls maybe each one has more
power than even wenmu himself realized
but i still think there's probably a
little bit more to dissect that we're
probably not gonna get i'm just
speculating now in the mcu past ten
rings members razza and jackson norris
bragged about the tin rings history of
conquest in the asian continent the bow
and arrow once was the pinnacle of
weapons technology it allowed the great
genghis khan to rule from the pacific
to the ukraine he was a warrior king he
inspired generations of men through the
middle ages and now we actually get to
see that history as when wu whips his
ten rings into a shield that deflects
all enemy arrows the previous pinnacle
of technology now being supplanted by
his and i love this shot where he
extends his rings hovering from his fist
like a collapsible baton just like we
saw norris use in all hail the king now
the film returns to these extensive
flashbacks throughout the narrative so
for now just to stick with the
chronology when wu travels through a
bamboo forest and discovers a clearing
guarded by zhang li fala chen's
character who duels him in this
beautiful acrobatic ballet with
movements that are actually based on tai
chi contrastingly the combat style of
win woo in the style that he trains his
son and all of his warriors is based on
wing chun a traditional southern chinese
kung fu but zhang li's style reigns
supreme as she knocks him off balance
her fighting style incorporates air
bending something the people of tallow
seem to be skilled at and it gives him a
special connection to the earth that win
woo's mastery over tech that is actually
alien from another world can't really
compete with she's literally on her home
turf it's a lovely story that we get to
see and it's a genre referred to as
wushia you may have also seen it in
titles like crouching tiger hidden
dragon it refers to mythological
romances set amidst picturesque natural
landscapes that's how johnner and i met
mm-hmm yeah they shared that look
there's a pokemon battle around they're
great yeah right
locked
and then we locked eyes with each other
we knew and yeah like that is one of my
favorite moments in the whole film
because i think it's such good visual
storytelling where you're watching this
guy the mandarin or wentwo all these
years conquering and then the one person
who can actually defeat him or put up a
good fight towards him you see him
falling in love with her over the course
of this fight like you're swept up in
the romance of it i just think it's a
beautifully realized sequence overall
and has some of the best storytelling
within a fight that i've seen in you
know modern-day american cinnamon in
quite a long time the cinematographer of
this film was bill pope who actually
shot the matrix and you can see the
parallels and the warm color tones and
the wire work and the way zhang lee died
the green
has been bullet now the rings glow blue
whenever they're used by win-woo
contrasting the golden colors associated
with shanxi and his mother and her
people blue is a colder color tone
associated with death since that really
is how win-woo uses these rings whereas
gold is associated with sunlight in life
wenwu gives himself a chance at life by
locking his rings away giving up
immortality falling in love with zhang
li and having two children chongqi and
jai ling their mother gives them both
these green pendant necklaces but the
fun comes to an end when when wu's
former enemies find him the iron gang
and they attack while he's away killing
shine lee now it is interesting that
they are called the iron gang and iron
man is a long time enemy to the mandarin
comics but that might just be a parallel
i'm seeing so in his grief
he gets his revenge and brutally trains
his son into a killing machine to follow
in his footsteps he does this with the
help of his lieutenant death dealer
based on the killer death dealer lee
shin ling in the comics and let's not
forget to shout out death dealer played
by andy lee from the hit youtube channel
marshall club check out that interview
that we did when we ordered strong chi
to kill the head of the iron gang and
shanghai never returns home afterward
leaving his sister behind bringing us to
the modern day in san francisco chongqi
going by the name sean played by simulu
lives in a garage and there's a poster
on his wall for the movie
a martial arts action comedy a must-see
which also features the use of iron
strength bracelets he and his friend
katie played by aquafina work as valets
at the fairmont hotel i feel like we
gotta get key and peel to bring back
their ballet sketches
yeah
exactly they were just right behind at
the next station
waiting to tap them out for a break
several other marvel heroes have been
introduced as the owners of nice sports
cars as opposed to the people who park
them changji eats breakfast with katie's
family but on the way in outside the
building there's a poster reading
post-split anxiety you are not alone
national blip support hotline i guess
kind of like a post-in-game version of
what steve rogers had in end game but
now this for people going through the
kind of drama monaco rambo went through
at the hospital or that poor midtown
high tuba player who got tackled
there's also a poster for something
called lipsticks
yeah which according to interviews with
the screenwriters is a dating app for
those who were blipped
exactly what it looks like
you got a new disney plush show his
grandmother's late and katie and her
mother debate the importance of
superstitiously clinging to the memory
of dead loved ones which is our first
hit at this movie's deeper theme of
ancestral grief chongqi as a character
wants to escape the bloodshed of his
ancestry while his father lets his grief
drive him mad and threaten to spread
literal soullessness across the world so
shanghi must learn to channel his pain
from his father into something different
something positive which is an idea
director daniel destin credits said was
key to his own journey of self-discovery
while crafting this film i think that
scene is the thing that really sets the
tone and not maybe not in the way the
tone of the mood is captured in that
scene but really the themes explore
because there is that line in there you
know moving on is an american thing yeah
and then this whole thing with when woo
is he just can not move on whatsoever
even the little detail like he goes to
light her candle before trying to break
open the portal yeah so it's such
dedication these rings symbolize that
ancestral weight dragging when woo down
but when transferred to his son they
change color and become a force for good
katie tells chongqi about her art of
confusion defense tactic which is
randomly singing the eagles hotel
california ironically katie and chungchi
work at a hotel in california where they
may feel like they in the words of the
song can check out any time they like
but they can never leave now they sing
aladdin's a whole new world in karaoke
reflecting their escapist fantasies of
trying to find a whole new world but
then in the post-credits scene they
hilariously come back to hotel
california with wong because as he said
there's no turning back they're now
trapped in this avengers crisis world
and they can never leave katie and
shanxi get jumped on a bus with amazing
stunt work that keeps your eye on the
real object of this fight not shanghi
himself but his necklace meanwhile in
the early rounds of the fight you'll
notice razer frist glowers at them from
the back of the bus with fighter florian
mantianu playing the assassin from the
comics watching this all go down is
comedian zack cherry as cleve yo what up
y'all it's your boy cliff coming at you
live on the bus i actually did take a
little bit of martial arts as a youth so
i'm going to try and grade this fight as
we're going this same guy previously
appeared in spider-man homecoming he
told spider-man to do a flip zach cherry
went on stephen colbert pushing a
campaign for do a flip guy to get his
own mcu spin-off so it's awesome to see
him keep it going now look closely at
the focus on clev's live stream they
include at capupia saying these dudes
are regretting their life decisions
darkness saying unreal with a purple
background this could be auntie agnes
aka agatha harkness often clad in purple
not really sure what her reality is
because at this point over in west view
she's stuck in a trance after wanda
maximoff left her there just watching
youtube i love that you went there i
just love that you went she's did
transgender just on youtube watch live
streams
trying to get her message out
in whatever subconscious way she can we
must connect them we must we have to we
must especially to one division i think
that's the logical choice
that's hilarious man and then there's
climbing guy 3000 who says i literally
can't even this could be an alias of
peter parker who loves climbing and he
could be shouting out the guy who loved
us three three thousand dollars several
commenters praised seong chi's fighting
skills calling him bus boy which is a
bit of viral fame similar to how peter
parker initially got the attention of
the whole world and of tony stark in
online videos just like this and he was
a boy literally also saving a city bus
and let's not forget the director said
that if there's one superhero he'd love
to see shang chi fight or team up with
spider-man planting the seeds even
brought back the comedian from
spider-man homecoming right to be in
this movie i think there are seeds
planted here for spider-man their whole
scene will be on a phone
because they're both on phones here oh
jonah comedy and the cut back into it
don't worry and after he takes down a
few of them the extra extra award goes
to jean jacket here who crosses her arms
until the guy falls and her eyes bulge
out at chiang chi now just seeing the
more stylistic choreography of his
owners
combat is more practical in slapstick he
uses his jacket he springs off the
elasticity of the bust joint bellows all
parts of his environment to subdue his
foes this style was made famous by
jackie chan films all coming from this
movie's stunt coordinator the late brad
allen who was a member of the jackie
chan stunt team receives a lovely
tribute in this movie's credits and you
can see more of this intricate stunt
work later in the scaffolding fight
chongqi uses the planks balanced on the
bamboo to both swing himself down to the
lower level while seesawing it to knock
someone in the head and then later
knocks down an enemy to turn that person
into a bridge to run across and then
knock them down it's all like a big
elaborate game of mousetrap it's super
fun to watch but back to the bus fight
it all goes down in three acts the
second act begins as the bus enters the
tunnel and notice the camera stays on
chung chi from the exterior of the bus
as he works his way down it from right
to left he throws dudes out the window
just kind of mows them down paralleling
the amazing lateral camera movement in
the iconic hallway fight in the 2003
movie old boy but the third act of this
battle creates this hilarious crisis of
katie having to take the wheel now as
razer fist slices the bellows look
carefully because at first you can see
the necklace around shangchi's neck but
then he turns his back to us and razor
fist starts moving his other hand around
and then when shangshi kicks razor fist
into the back as it tears off around the
turn and he leaps at us into the brain
you can see
his neck is bare on his neck oh
great
moment great attention to detail damn
damn that's great anyone can disappear
at any moment so again yes this is set
after endgame and notice how shanghi
wears a silmar high school shirt that on
the back says class of 2017. so if 10
years have now passed since xiangxi ran
away when he was 14 years old if he
graduated in the year 2017 that would
set this movie in july 2024 by the jazz
music festival
studying this at almost exactly the same
time as spider-man apart from home when
he was in europe and also allowing us to
conclude that chongqi to be this old
must have survived the snap and must
have had to age during those five years
oh my god there's so much to keep up
with so much time-like continuity here
even marvel's starting to lose it a bit
who was here during and before the blip
yeah because a lot of the questions i'm
noticing they keep coming up was like
how far exactly does this take place
after end game that's what a lot of
these questions have been for post
avengers and game movies i feel like
marvel intentionally has not directly
acknowledged it from time to time so
that was actually all these release
dates moving around more than ever
they're like it's just you know it's not
long after it's like there was one
little hiccup with spider-man homecoming
became an outrage so now they're like
okay let's not confuse ourselves let's
just uh you know keep it kind of vague
in the timeline here let people like
eric voss look at jazzplue's ads to see
exactly when the timeline might take
place chungchi follows a postcard
leading them to macau along with katie
to this cage fighting club owned by his
sister jai ling but operated by ronnie
chang as john john this club is called
the golden daggers club now the golden
dagger was a name from early sheng chi
comics master of kung fu number 44 and
it was the name of one of boo manchu's
subsidiary groups now in the various
low-level fights in the rooms of the
background is a sumo wrestler there's
also a female warrior no stunt actress
jay ju returns in this movie after she
played a black widow agent in the movie
and in the credits she is credited as
widow meaning she is the same character
from black widow which might be why she
now wears black with the red belt and
she must be one of those freed black
hoodies
that's great and now she's fighting him
a cow give her a spin off there's also a
fighter with flesh glowing red orange
apparently a recipient of ames extremist
treatment from iron man 3 suggesting
that some of aldrich killian's test
subjects might have gotten away from
that battle and one of them now has this
life fighting in cage matches on the
other side of the world it's kind of
crazy to know there's like some widows
just they are going to carry on in some
way yeah i guess they follow black widow
movie black widows what do we all do now
yeah we need job placement for all you
guys these highly specialized skills
that is a wonderful easter egg right
there that if you pay attention to the
credits and then you find out that oh
that is a continuity carrying on from
the other marvel movie release earlier
this year this is pretty insane that's
that's a really clever one never would
have noticed that it was for eric boss
pointed that out man the extremist one
obviously yeah but um yeah the widow one
that's a great that's like you're doing
a black widow and iron man three easter
egg all in one one little kid yeah but
the marquee batch of course is wong dr
strange's fellow sorcerer fighting
abomination now remember abomination was
emil blonsky tim roth who fought the
edward norton version of hulk and harlem
in the 2008 film and we believe has been
imprisoned ever since it is amazing to
see him return in the mcu here this
version of him looks different with a
greener color and head bins he also
wears pants similar to his appearance
from the comics but this change was
never explained i presume the way hulk's
redesigned between the 2008 film and the
avengers wasn't really explained either
well the producer did come out recently
and he kept it really simple he was like
i just felt it was in need of a
change and update now it was like that
simple there was a real like storyline
purpose dude it was like i just felt
like i needed an update yeah why not
fill in the blanks in your head of like
oh maybe the past few years he yeah
through some fins
there's an actual story context to it
other than just we know how to redesign
the look after abomination actually hits
wong huang gets him back by opening the
portal to make abomination knock himself
out similar to how wong used clever
portal tricks to beat big boy call
obsidian infinity war later the two
appear to retreat to what looks like a
facility that looks like it has a
high-tech containment cell in there
maybe where blonsky is being forced to
stay when he's not sparring in macau
with wong this facility could be the
raft prison or some other facility
overseen by thaddeus ross because maybe
blonsky is being allowed to train as
part of ross and valve's upcoming
thunderbolts initiative and maybe they
only trusted wong this sorcerer to be
his chaperone meanwhile chang chi fights
his sister behind him is a flag that
looks like the flag of magipore the
southeast asian country that appeared in
the fact in the winter soldier the post
guard we found out was sent not by
xiling but by their father a trick to
trap both of them in the same place at
the same time chung chi fights the tin
rings warriors on the scaffolding and
fights death dealer until his father
appears and lays a gentle but terrifying
ring-equipped wrist on his shoulder so
they all return to the ten rings
compound where when wu reconciles the
mcu's past depictions of the mandarin
legend with his truth laughing how
aldrich killian invented the mandarin
boogeyman identity naming it after a
chicken dish and we actually see on his
video screens footage of tony stark's
captivity by the tin rings in the first
iron man film i think this is a really
great thing it does mirror the comics in
so many ways they had a fu manchu
originally introduced to shanghi's
father and the course of the mandarin
and like there's been like a lot of
times with like oh no it's problematic
now we need to change the way this
character is being portrayed when you
update it we need to make adjustments to
it so then mandarin is very different
now than it was when it first originally
debuted kind of like how what happened
here with the live-action cinema you
know you have the mandarin here being
appropriated by trevor slattery aldrich
killian that did not go over well with
audiences not really because of the
whole racial thing there were some
problematic areas with that but really
it was just the fact that they depicted
the mandarin wrong and then they come
over here and now people like what
they've done with trevor slattery the
way how in the comics the mandarin had
changed over time due to backlash and
they had to course correct it they've
done that now with the live action
movies with the mandarin themselves so i
think it's kind of neat how weirdly
unintentionally has mirrored the
trajectory of the comics to a certain
extent when wu plugs shang chi and jai
ling's necklace pendants into the eyes
of the wooden dragon carving in his
shrine causing water to flow out and
mystically bend revealing the path in
the bamboo forest maze that will lead to
topo zhang li's hidden kingdom that he
was never allowed to enter and where he
now believes her soul to be trapped in a
cave voices calling out to him now i
know they have to go underneath where
the water is like the the waterfall
after they go through the bamboo forest
correct me here couldn't when would have
taken a helicopter to where that tunnel
is
i suppose maybe you know i don't know i
i would imagine that if he tried to
there would be some kind of other
provision think about it if this thing
is ancient someone must have tried to
catapult over it or whatever so yeah
that's a great question actually could
anyone ever find that tunnel entrance
before cars were invented going through
that forest seems like there's no way
you can do it on horse yeah you have to
have headaches
yeah or have super speed yeah right
right yeah
unless the
forest accommodates how quickly you're
moving because michelle yo does say that
there's other people who tried coming
here to break that uh where the the soul
suckers are healthy my mind was like
ain't pulled out going how did other
people get here without a car
probably the most possible way you got a
really really great rider with a really
just rock steady horse fair enough now
in the marvel comics tahloe is one of
the god realms a small pocket dimension
adjacent to earth the great canopy of
heaven home to celestial dragons and the
phoenix like fang huang the wooden
quillin beasts and the canine-like
heitae and the race known as the jean
i'm sorry if i mispronounced any of that
and surviving in this compound's dungeon
is trevor slattery ben kingsley serving
as the jester he recaps what he went
through in iron man 3 and in the all
hail the king short and when they
stumble upon him here he was quoting the
knock knock knock monologue from
shakespeare's macbeth the drunken porter
from act 2 scene 3 and in that scene the
porter imagines himself as the man
answering the gate of hell reinforcing
one of the themes of that play that the
castle setting is really a form of hell
for the characters and for trevor
slattery this is a speech that amused
win woo enough into keeping him around
which is super ironic since trevor ends
up as a supporting player at this
movie's hell's gate as it opens also fun
fact palpatine actor ed mcdarmod played
the porter in the famous 1978 production
that starred in mckellen as macbeth and
judy dench as lady macbeth he's
accompanied by the adorable morris whom
katie calls a chicken pig but morris is
actually a dijang from chinese mythology
associated with the personification of
hundun a legendary faceless being of
primal chaos this guy actually appears
way cuter
chaos other mythological beings who
later appear in tahloe they break out
and steal razer fist's car and since we
never hear his name spoken aloud in the
movie the fact that his name is written
all over his car is really the only way
we learn his name using morris to guide
them through the bamboo forest maze
until they reach tallow where morris
reunites with others of his kind and
they see lots of other mythological
creatures including the hooligans that's
a nine-tailed fox-like creature the food
these are the big lion-like creatures
that guard shrines and temples in pairs
these are also known as guardian lions
and when wu actually has statue versions
of them at the gates of the tin rings
compound and the vermilion bird
representing the element of fire and
that turquoise horse with the face of a
dragon is the longma which really just
translates to horse dragon seeing one of
these is supposed to be considered an
omen of a legendary sage ruler which if
you think about it both chongqi and his
sister xialing will evolve into by the
end of this film the talo people are led
by guangbo played by yuen ma legendary
hong kong actor and stuntman who worked
with bruce lee in the 1670s with films
like fist of fury and enter the dragon
in the popularity isn't he also
particular
among the people of tallow is michelle
yo
nan lee's sister who explains how they
are connected to this benevolent dragon
that they call the great protector who
for them has fought off a demonic entity
from another realm that along with its
smaller tentacled drones feeds on souls
now the creature is only ever given the
name of dweller in darkness and none
explains how it fed on their vast cities
i thought it was mega solstice
beyond this world this is the beast
behind the seal who has been in wynwoo's
head disguising himself as the voice of
his deceased white which is similar to
lovecraftian monsters like cthulhu and
yarlathotep who form psychic telepathic
links with mortals driving them crazy
nan says the dweller of darkness
promises your greatest desires an oddly
specific faustian offer which could link
with the cosmic dark magic of peter
parker's wish fulfillment spell in
spider-man no way home and the pulsing
beacon inside the ten rings that wong
discovers in the post-credits scene
could be setting up a supernatural
interdimensional threat that the marvel
heroes will face in doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness a villain like
schumachorath or one of the other
tentacled elder gods or the demon cathan
who drafted the darkhold and in the
comics initially cursed wanda maximoff
with her sorcery or maybe a figure like
nightmare or mephisto
this beast could have been a weapon of
their making damn this is so crazy
because we really don't know what
specific direction marvel is headed
right now we have ideas going more
cosmic we know against celestials we
know we got kang multiverse of madness
we still don't know who the villain is
directly of that we're dealing with the
multiverse we opened up supernatural
dimensions now here as seen in what if
episode 4. it's just kind of crazy to
think of what the trajectory of phase 4
is especially after hearing all this
it's like i thought it was gonna become
like oh we're gonna be all king focused
now the way how we got all thanos
focused in phase one through three but
now it's like whoa what what directions
are we really headed now because yeah we
have all the setups for all these things
that he's talking about we don't know
like what one direction's headed yeah
it's like they've drawn this air of
chaotic expansion and possibility but
yeah they haven't really centered it on
one specific figure which actually i i
like that i prefer it feels more like a
comic book series could these creatures
be linked to the one we saw in chongqi
well while not everything we see on the
animated what if series will cross over
into the live-action mcu this definitely
parallels shangchi's hints of this
demonic tentacled monster from other
realms trying to absorb life forces yeah
and it would not surprise me at all if
doctor strange's multiverse of madness
ends up establishing this soul sucker
and the what if monster as part of the
same family of elder god-esque beans if
not the same creature the seal we
learned is formed from dragon scales of
the great protector dragon scales also
form the armor and the weaponry of these
tallow guardians and shanxi receives his
comic accurate suit a fabric made of
these same scales which along with
zhang's new clothes were left to both of
them by their mother and none carries
that legacy of her sister by training
shang chi in that tai chi style that his
mother used to defeat his father win woo
by opening up his fist into an open palm
and setting up chiang chi in the final
battle to defeat his father using that
same kind of dance and beautiful eye
contact that we saw in that earlier
scene also in this training dojo here
the base of it is windy and serpentine
the body of the great protector showing
how in this setting they are bound by
the dragon
and his forces who arrive leading to
this vicious battle between the ten
rings and the warriors of tallow the
father and son face off but when woo
blasts shanxi into the water and begins
hammering away at the gate allowing soul
suckers to leak into this realm one of
them snatches death dealer i am with
audiences not just because andy lee
plays him but i am with audiences on the
fact that it's kind of a bummer how like
death dealer isn't going to be much of a
character and he's so
cool it's like he's like obviously a
super cool looking character and yeah he
doesn't get to do that much and he's
really is linked to chongchi's traumatic
past so i thought we would get like at
least some personal showdown between the
two two warring sides decide to join
forces against these soul suckers
because only talo weaponry works against
them meanwhile deep in the water shang
chi awakens the great protector and
reconfronts his father at the foot of
this crumbling seal now after shang chi
failed to defeat his father using the
same wing chun combat that his father
taught him this time he disarms win woo
the same way zhang li did using the more
graceful tai chi movements bending the
rings to his will and seeing that his
great love lives on not in the imposter
from beyond but in the grace of the
learns the core lesson of this film of
ancestral grief that the pain of our
past isn't reason to destroy its fuel
meant to re-channel to bring life and i
would argue despite this being a pretty
strong origin story for chiang chi in
the mcu as a whole this movie is less of
the story of the hero but like other
great marvel films like avengers
infinity war captain america winter
soldier and black panther this is truly
the story of the villain with a complex
soul win woo is truly the heart of this
film and it makes it a more captivating
story in my opinion
all while the rest worked together to
take down the mega soul sucker including
an amazingly lucky arrow hit by katie
they send lanterns out on the water to
memorialize the fallen and leave it to
xialing to dismantle the ten rings
network but as we learn in the second
post-credits scene she actually takes
over the throne and expands the tin
rings operation to return in either a
sequel or a disney plus series i
personally hope to oversee a fighting
tournament of eccentric fighters from
the mcu katie tells their friends of her
drinks that shang-chi defeated the
monster by doing a kamehameha fireball
of course not a dragon ball z and yeah
that is kind of the move song she used
to kill it and after not being believed
by their friends katie and shang chi are
summoned by wong to join them in the
sanctum sanctorum where in the
post-credits scene they meet bruce
banner and captain marvel learn of the
pulsing beacon in the rings all of which
i went into in another video i love how
the closing image of this film has
shengchi joining wong through a portal
ring a way of showing how when these
rings glowed blew they were heavy
burdens chaining shang chi to death to
the pain of his father but now as they
glow golden they represent a magical
gateway to another world to life for
this future avenger you can support new
rock stars by checking out our emergency
options at yourrockstarsmerch.com like
this amazing what if shirt design that
i'm wearing you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea follow and
subscribe to new rockstars thanks for
watching bye fantastic work man wow
fantastic work heck yeah did that all
off of one viewing in the theater
obviously did not torrent it at all no
no in order to make this video possible
guys subscribe to new rockstars if you
haven't done so you can subscribe to us
hit that like button thank you again nr
for putting that together last but not
least let's do a pic
david gandy i just wanted to shout you
out on this video because i mean we've
had all this shang chi stuff going on
over the weekend he even jumped into the
shang chi live stream this afternoon you
know showed us a little love and i mean
it's weird i've become jealous of you
because in the past couple of years
you've been
on your own
and the thing is like that reminds me of
like me when i was younger you know it's
like i got some of the old forms and
stuff
muscle memory but i really am kind of
longing to like get back in and like
brush up so that one day you and i
you know can take on the world david
gandy us white guys we need to stick
together and do the martial arts and you
know show people that uh you know it's
not just brad allen out there
but uh seriously dude i hope you're well
thank you again for like being the
person to open up the door for us to be
able to talk to andy lee though
we're cool uh yeah
be well and we'll catch you next time
[Music]